Say when.
When You'll never guess
who's here.
Think 90s no Bojack Horseman
from horsing around.
No I mean
he got a little fatter
but it's definitely him.
He looks really sad.
It's hilarious.
Get over here now .
I told you I don't know
where it is.
Don't put things in my butt
if you want them back.
And hold for
Princess Carolyn please.
Thanks Laura.
When your walking alone
because gelicals are angelicas
do gelicals do and geli-
Bojack.
It's your favorite agent.
Yeah some agent
You couldn't even give me
in the room for warhorse.
There were like 10 horses
in that movie.
I didn't need
to be the warhorse.
Listen dummy I want to make sure
you're all set
for your first day
with Diane tomorrow.
Is she going to ask me
a bunch of personal questions.
The woman we're paying
to goes write your memoir.
Yeah probably.
OK all right
there's no need to get catty.
Are you going to say.
Is not going to say catty.
Alright what were you
going to say?
I was going to say catty
because you're a cat.
Goodbye Bojack Laura
I know
you're listening
you got it right?
Laura do not respond to him.
Goodbye Bojack.
She got it.
Excuse me.
I just wanted you to know
that you ruined
someone else's night tonight
and I hope you have
enough decency
to at least feel
a little bit crappy about it.
Excuse me? I was actually
already in a bad mood
but I thought maybe
for one night
I could go out to a bar
and try to forget about myself
but now because of you
and your friends
I feel more self-conscious
than ever.
If we were bothering you so much
why didn't you just leave?
because I didn't think of that
and now I feel stupid.
Look I have aright to be hear-
No.
Maybe because you're skinny
and maybe because you're pretty
you're used to getting away
with things
but I want you to know
that your actions
have enough effect on others.
I hate you and you are
a horrible person.
And you not understanding
that you're a horrible person
doesn't make you
less of a horrible person.
You think I'm pretty?